ellie kemper ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
you
this is the ray of sunshine my friends
before my eyes really are i mean you
can't say your name without the
synonymous joy
comedy beauty no go on no i'm kidding
okay no that's very kind of you because
all of that back at you a hundred fold
drew very much so thank you for saying
that well i've always loved you so much
no but i never knew
that you might have a personal
synonymous
revelation for me
yes so let me set this up okay um when
we first started the show we were lucky
enough to have ellie as a guest
i was new
uh i didn't really know what i was doing
uh we were in a pandemic so we were on
zooms which also added extra layers of
well really there's just no excuse um
okay well for those of you who may have
missed ellie's last appearance well i
there's no other way to say it i could
only show it that'll sell it
the wonderful ellie kemper
you have
been this beacon of joy and comedy
beautiful
funny charming whimsical the office
kimmy schmidt bridesmaids scene stealer
brilliant woman that you are you say
ellie kemper and people are like oh my
gosh
gosh darn it i just want to turn it over
to you i have like such deep respect for
you
it's funny to hang out with you she is
just so good i mean you're just
thank you for saying that
no no no
i i i mean that it it changed my life it
changed the way i do my job
uh i thought i was trying to honor you
and all i did was talk over you you did
not that at all
and by the way i want to tell you when
we had our fantastic conversation that i
was so lucky to be a part of i did not
note i thought it was in equal equal
parts i noticed a banter back and forth
only upon watching that first of all
that's like you're just showering me
with praise it's beautiful
but yeah i i guess i didn't talk as much
but i
i don't think you could have
i zamboni do you know
you came out flat like i i literally
steamrolled
with love so this time i i feel like um
i'll just be quiet now okay
and i'll take i'll take the floor yes
okay
um there are a few things i wanted to
talk about you guys my five-year-old
really loves animals and he's really
into ages and numbers right now and
everything and full of questions as you
know kids ask a lot of questions so he
asked me a long time ago when the first
centipede appeared i have no idea when
the first centipede appeared i googled
it and it's 430 million years ago
i didn't stop there though because then
i realized 430 million years ago we
always talk about um
dinosaurs which apparently were only 230
million years ago so this means that
centipedes which are not extinct have
been on this earth for 200 million years
longer than dinosaurs is that crazy you
always think dinosaurs are the oldest so
then i looked up cockroaches because
everyone always refers to the
cockroaches the most resilient insect
ever
there's some debate on the age of
cockroaches but even the oldest estimate
says only 350 million years ago was the
first cockroach so do you understand why
are we giving more credit to the
centipedes that's what i want to know
you know
and some now
anyway all this made me wonder how old
are humans and by that i mean modern
humans homo sapiens they're only 300 000
years old
300 000 years old centipedes are 430
million years ago anyway
it was a really interesting biology
lesson and it also somehow humbled me
and now i think
maybe you understand why i didn't have
the floor last time
are you kidding me
i feel like we're your lucky kids who
get to hear this amazing who doesn't
want to have mom
teach them the ways of life and the
facts of science and nature google
google i think we like to say cockroach
because it's such a good word cockroach
so satisfying to say cockroach it is
i refer to i say cockroaches all the
time like oh that cockroach
you mean to describe a person yes
i do
[Music]
you